Thank you so much for coming.
Is this on? Can you hear me? Yes. I
could probably just yell but anyway.
Thank you very much for coming. You
know, it's interesting that we heard in
the preamble that this group is not
about hating anyone or about bigotry or
any of these things and it's unfortunate
that that kind of thing is necessary but
anybody who has been to more than one
act meeting
knows full well why it is necessary but
I'm here to tell you, very happy to tell
you that it's all over now. It's okay
now to oppose Sharia. I want to thank
Jay Leno for being here and Michelle
Obama.
Jay stand, where is Jay?
Um,
actually we and you may if you may have
heard that Jay Leno indeed has been
leading protests against the Beverly
Hills Hotel for having the unfortunate
misfortune of being owned by the Sultan
of Brunei who has just imposed the
fullness of Sharia in Brunei, the
fullness of Islamic law, that is the
institutionalized oppression of women,
the institutionalized oppression of
gays, non-Muslims and the denial of the
freedom of speech and the denial of the
freedom of conscience.
And suddenly we discover that Hollywood
is a hotbed of Islamophobia.
And Jay Leno and Ellen DeGeneres and
several others, all the all these
Hollywood literati were out in front of
the Beverly Hills Hotel protesting
against this horrible imposition of a
law that nobody has ever seen in the
world before or ever heard of. It's
never been imposed anywhere else.
And it's absolutely egregious that it
should have been imposed in Brunei now.
And because
the Beverly Hills Hotel is owned by the
Sultan, therefore it has to be the
epicenter of anti-Sharia protests.
And so I thought surely Jay would be
here because after all we've been on
this for years.
And where is Jay been?
Uh maybe uh the uh first lady will
formulate a new hashtag to set it all up
for us and put it in context.
Uh we also see that it's now even
possible to be opposed to Sharia in the
White House.
In the Barack Obama White House.
With the with with the president's wife
holding the the the famous hashtag bring
back our girls which we know of course
the Islamic jihadists of Boko Haram will
immediately see that on their Twitter
feeds.
Be
embarrassed
at how they have offended one of the
nation's
most prominent human rights activists
will therefore free the girls and uh
get gainfully employed and everything
will be okay.
Now, the funny thing is of course that
Michelle Obama never did and never would
explain what exactly the abduction of
the school girls has to do with Islamic
law and why it's connected to Jay Leno's
protests against the Beverly Hills Hotel
and she may not even know.
But in fact
as many of you no doubt know
Boko Haram, the uh group that abducted
the schoolgirls in Nigeria, is acting
according to basic teachings of the
Quran, the holy book of Islam, and
Islamic law. It is perfectly permissible
within Islamic law to kidnap people.
In chapter 47 verse 4 of the Quran,
the chapter entitled Muhammad, says,
"When you meet the unbelievers, strike
at their necks."
And then
you have four choices. You can You take
hostages, and you can enslave them, you
can kill them,
you can free them outright or free them
for ransom. And this is laid out in this
verse, chapter 47 verse 4, and it
becomes the basis for that
four different choices you can make
for what you do with the people you have
kidnapped.
Non-believers.
Probably Michelle Obama does not know
when she holds her famous hashtag
hashtag bring back our girls, that 90%
of the girls in question are Christians,
and that they were forcibly converted to
Islam.
With the Abubakar Shekau, the head of
Boko Haram, saying that he would free
the girls who refused to convert to
Islam if
they the uh Nigerian government freed
various prisoners, various jihadi
prisoners.
So, in other words, he's acting strictly
in accord with Islamic law, and strictly
in accord with the Quran. He's taking
hostages who are non-believers.
He is either enslaving them,
which is perfectly permissible
according to chapter 47 verse 4, or
freeing them for ransom, which is also
perfectly permissible in accord with
chapter 47 verse 4.
Not only that, but the Quran also says
in chapter 4 verse 3 and chapter 4 verse
24 that a man can have up to four wives
as long as he treats them equitably. So,
it's okay to do so.
And
the captives of his right hand.
The captives of his right hand, if you
read the commentaries on Islamic law,
are
infidel women who have been captured,
who have been kidnapped, and who are
pressed into slavery, specifically sex
slavery.
And I can hear you now, "Wait a minute,
Spencer, this is just lurid. This is
This is unbelievable.
This is a little bit salacious."
Surely this can't be so. This is a major
This is a great world religion. I read
about it in my ninth grade book.
And
great world religions don't have sex
slaves.
Well, with one exception.
It is in the Quran, and therefore
there is no appealing against it, and
there is no reforming it or changing it.
It was perfectly well understood in
Muhammad's time, according to the
traditions about what Muhammad said and
did.
There was a time, for example, there's a
Hadith, a story of Muhammad, in which
the Muslim warriors come up to him in
battle, and they say, "We have uh
captured these women,
and we want to sleep with them.
And we just don't know if it's okay
to practice various forms of uh
prevention of birth."
I'm trying to be delicate here.
And Muhammad gives his permission, in
short. But in other words, the issue in
question was about the contraception. It
was not actually about whether they
could kidnap and sleep with infidel
women. That was taken for granted as
being perfectly okay.
And it is part of the purported
revelations that he received from Allah.
Now,
that means that it's just as much part
of Islamic law as
what the uh Sultan of Brunei is doing.
And so now it's suddenly fashionable.
It's okay to oppose Sharia.
The thing is I would doubt that if
anybody actually asked Jay Leno
that what he what the relationship is
between Sharia and Islam, if he would
know or if he even knows that Sharia has
anything to do with Islam at all.
He probably thinks that it's a twisted
hijacked version of Islam that's
practiced by extremists.
And this is not just because Jay Leno
might not be as as well informed as he
should be or as knowledgeable as he
should be. I don't know the man. He may
be sharp as a tack. The question is
though, how is he going to be able to
counteract the fact that he and the rest
of us have been lied to by government,
by law enforcement, and by media in an
absolutely thoroughgoing and consistent
fashion for 12 years now and more
about this threat.
And the lies continue.
For example, I'm just saying that
Michelle Obama probably has no idea that
this has anything to do with Islamic law
and that's also because nobody's telling
her.
Not only does after every jihad attack
and every jihad action in the world does
her husband and other leaders in the
western world not only do they all stand
up and say, "Well, you know this has
nothing to do with Islam."
But also the media does the same thing.
Just over the last few days in Jihad
Watch I've responded to two
articles, one at CNN and one at the
Huffington Post by Muslim leaders
saying this has nothing to do with
Islam. What Boko Haram has done is
absolutely contrary to the tenets of the
Quran.
Now there's a funny thing about those
articles. In the first place, did you
know that the name of Boko Haram is not
really Boko Haram? Boko Haram means
Western education is sin. And the idea
behind that, usually when they're talk
when they when that is explained in the
mainstream media, it's it's it's
explained in terms of and they they're
sort of like Luddites with AK-47s. They
they don't like modern technology except
for the guns.
And so they don't like going to school.
They don't like that book learning.
But actually, Western education is sin
refers to the fact that they object to
any education that's not based on the
Quran and Islam.
That's their problem with Western
education.
They're perfectly fine with modern
technology, especially the weapons.
But there's more. Boko Haram's That's
not really their name. That's their
nickname. That's what they're popularly
known as.
Their real name is the Party of the
People of the Sunnah for Dawah and
Jihad.
The Party of the People of the Sunnah
for Dawah and Jihad. Sunnah is accepted
Islamic practice. The Islamic laws that
are extrapolated from the Quran and the
deed.
Dawah is Islamic proselytizing.
So you have a group that is officially
and invalidly and solely and wholly
Islamic
in its motivations.
But these two articles, the one in CNN
and the one in the Huffington Post,
neither one of them
actually dealt with the justifications
for
taking infidel women, kidnapping them,
and making them into sex slaves that are
in the Quran that I just outlined. Both
of them purported to say both of them
purported to make a case
that this had nothing to do with Islam.
And that this was completely in
violation of the Quran, but neither one
of them actually mentioned
the verses about taking captives of the
right hand
or the verses about kidnapping and
either enslaving or ransoming or killing
or whatever.
Neither of them even mentioned it. Now
you see,
that's the difference between reform and
deception.
It's very important that we all grasp
the difference between reform and
deception.
If I were a Muslim and I were writing
about the Quran and I were a Muslim
reformer and I objected to what Boko
Haram had done,
then let me ask you this. Do you think
this is reasonable? I would write and I
would say, "The Quran says that a man
can have up to four wives and take
captives of his right hand, which was
understood in the time of Muhammad,
according to the stories attributed to
him and in the in Islamic law as meaning
that a man can take sex slaves from
infidel women.
But this practice is in violation of
human rights and human dignity and
therefore must be rejected and we have
to formulate new understandings of these
verses and reject their literal meaning
and work against the Muslims who take
them seriously in the modern age."
That would be what reform would look
like. Have you ever seen it?
Me either.
What we see instead are all these people
saying, like Arsalan Iftikhar at CNN,
who used to be an official of the Muslim
Council of American Islamic Relations,
and a uh an Ahmadi uh Muslim in
Baltimore who wrote in The Huffington
Post.
They both just ignored these passages of
the Quran altogether.
And they quoted some others about
showing mercy and being compassionate
and quoting the passage from chapter 81
of the Quran about how the girl child
who was buried alive will ask for what
on Judgment day, for what reason was she
killed?
Well, that's nice, you know, I'm I'm
glad that's in there, but these girls
aren't being buried alive.
These girls are not That's That verse
simply doesn't apply to what their
situation is.
And so,
if they don't mention the reasons that
Boko Haram uses to justify their actions
on Islamic grounds, then they're not
going to convince Boko Haram or any
other Muslim who agrees with them that
what they're doing is wrong on Islamic
grounds.
What they're really trying to do is lull
the infidels into complacency so that we
don't get too exercised about this
happening and that we certainly don't do
anything to call upon Muslim communities
in Nigeria or in the West or anywhere
else to work to reform and to end this
practice and to teach against these
beliefs so that this kind of thing
doesn't happen again.
And that's the problem.
It's amazing to me, but it's not amazing
to me because I'm so used to it, but
it's still it ought to be offensive to
us. It ought to be amazing to us that we
have to start this meeting with
assurances that we're not racist and
bigoted.
It was not racist and bigoted to oppose
the Nazis and it's not racist and
bigoted to oppose groups like Boko
Haram.
As a matter of fact, it's really an
amazing thing that people would even
think that it is racist
to defend Nigerian
Christians who are being terrorized by
Boko Haram, Nigerian schoolgirls who are
being captured by them, Nigerians of all
of all creeds and and and perspectives
who are terrorized by this group.
That's
racism to support the victims.
You see how Orwellian is?
And yet in Boston
when a couple of white guys set off a
bomb at the Boston Marathon in the name
of Jihad and Islam for the same goals
and the same motives and the same
understanding as the Boko Haram group
has,
then it's racist to be upset about that.
And so it you know this race thing is
getting me very confused. I don't
understand it. Ibrahim Hooper of the
Council on American Islamic Relations is
blond-haired and blue-eyed and I'm
brown-eyed and swarthy and if I oppose
Ibrahim Hooper I'm a racist.
Ibrahim Hooper
goes on television, goes on Megyn Kelly
and trashes Ayaan Hirsi Ali
because she's racist.
Now wait a minute.
But what we see here of course is
a consistent campaign
that is designed
to discredit any
resistance to Jihad terror.
And they do it to everyone.
Every time and I mean without any
exception
every time anyone says anything that is
opposed to Jihad terror or to Islamic
law and its oppressive aspects or to
Islamic supremacism in any way, then
they are tarred and demonized, vilified,
smeared with the intention of being
marginalized altogether so that
the Jihad can advance unimpeded
and unopposed and people of goodwill
will be afraid
to speak out about it.
Now think about this. This is an
extraordinary thing.
This is an amazing thing that they've
done to us.
And it's really astonishing how well
it's worked. Look here, we have I was
told here before this is a very good
crowd for your group and you have we
have filled the room and a couple
hundred people here maybe or 150 I don't
know I don't know how well the capacity
is but it's a nice crowd and I thank you
all for coming.
But think about how many other people if
they heard about it would have thought
and certainly did think, "Oh wow, that
racist bigot is here in town."
Isn't it terrible that some people are
going to go see him? Go throw red meat
to the yard of rednecks.
And
imagine
in 1942
if there had been a meeting about the
motives and goals of the Nazis
and people had stayed away saying, "Oh
that would be hateful and bigoted to go
to that."
And the idea that they have so ingrained
in the American consciousness and in the
consciousness of the West at this point
that to oppose people who are on record
openly saying they want to destroy us
is hateful.
The idea that anybody would have taken
it seriously for a second is
astonishing.
But it's worked very well. I mean why
why don't we have a thousand people
here? Two thousand?
And it's not just about me. I mean to
hear anyone who would speak about these
things. Most people have no idea, right?
You know your friends, your family, your
co-workers no idea about this.
And if you talk about it they'll say,
"Oh you're going on about that again.
You know he's a little nutty about this
issue.
Stay away from that."
Am I right? Has this ever happened to
you? Exactly. So
let me show you how well it's worked.
Fort Dix
we all know about the Fort Hood Jihad
shooting but there was a plot a few
years before that at Fort Dix.
And at Fort Dix it was it was uh
also a racist thing. It was a bunch of
white guys from Albania.
And they were Muslims, and they were
going to go into Fort Dix and shoot as
many American soldiers as possible in
the name of Jihad and Islam before they
themselves would be killed, and then
they would go to paradise with the
virgins as per the Quran chapter 9 verse
111, paradise being guaranteed to those
who kill and are killed for Allah.
So, this never happened.
Why didn't it happen? They got caught.
How'd they get caught? By our wonderful
law enforcement apparatus? No. I'm going
to get to that later.
They got caught because of a kid,
17-year-old kid, Brian Morgenstern, in a
video store.
He worked at a video store.
And one of the Jihadis came in
with VHS tapes because what they liked
to do for fun was make some popcorn
and grab some non-alcoholic beer and
watch the Jihad videos, beheadings,
bombings,
gory stuff.
Allahu Akbar, the whole deal.
And they they liked this stuff because
that's the kind of people that they
were. And so,
the problem is they had it on VHS tapes.
So, they took it to the video store and
they asked Brian, "Can you transfer this
to DVD for us?"
Oh, jeez. And so, he's doing his job and
it's rolling by on the screen apparently
as he's transferring, and he's appalled
by what he sees. He's shocked to his
core by all this blood and gore that
he's seeing there and the glorification
of it, the obvious joy that is being
transmitted from the screen with this
blood and death as the Jihadis always
remind us that they love death. And they
say, "We will win because we love death
more than you love life." I'm not so
sure, but anyway, that's what they say.
Now,
Brian,
17 years old, doesn't know anything,
working in no offense to 17-year-olds,
working in a video store,
goes to his boss,
and he says, "Dude,
I'm seeing some really weird stuff in
these videos.
Should I go to the police, or would that
be racist?"
I kid you not.
Now, why would
a guy think for a minute that it might
be racist to report people for what they
apparently might have been planning in
terms of committing the same murder and
mayhem that he was seeing on the screen
in the United States?
Well, obviously, because he's breathed
that in in the culture.
That is part of our understanding of
what it means to resist jihad.
It means that you hate whole groups of
people just because of their skin color
or their national origin or whatever.
It doesn't mean you hate being blown up.
It doesn't mean you hate the idea of
kidnapping little schoolgirls and making
them into sex slaves. It doesn't mean
that you hate the idea that anybody who
criticizes a particular belief system is
has to live under death threats for the
rest of his life. No, no, no, it doesn't
mean any of that. It means you're
racist.
And it worked.
It worked.
Such that even groups like you, where
you were on the front lines, and you
were determined and willing and ready to
fight for freedom,
and you have to start out on a defensive
mode and say, "Well, you know, we're not
here to hate anybody."
Well, that ought don't want saying. And
I'm not saying I'm not criticizing.
Don't get me wrong. I think you you you
I thank God for groups like this.
And for all of you being here. I
understand why it is that that has to be
said. And I have defended myself a
thousand times against the same kinds of
charges. But I'm just trying to help you
to understand it as a tactic.
That
it has made people afraid to resist
jihad and to stand with us tonight.
And that was the point of it all along.
It was always a cynical
and self-serving attempt to shut down
any criticism of jihad terror. Now, the
thing about it is
is that
even that being said, it wouldn't have
mattered. And we wouldn't have to be on
the defensive ever.
And it wouldn't have made any difference
if it had just been groups like the
Council on American Islamic Relations
with its ties to Hamas and the Muslim
Brotherhood and other groups like that.
If it had just been them saying it,
well, that would have been easy. We
would have said, "Well, look, that Yeah,
they're Hamas. Of course they're going
to say that."
The problem is that it was picked up by
the mainstream media
such that there is no honest reporting.
Zero. None.
Of this by mainstream media reports. You
can just be sure that if there is a
story about jihad terror
in CNN or MSNBC or the New York Times or
the Washington Post, it's not going to
be fair to those who are resisting jihad
terror.
You can just be sure, 100% sure of that.
When I see a reporter from New York
Times emailing me or calling me
or the Washington Post
or CNN or any of them, I just know,
"Okay, yes, Mr. Prosecutor. How How
going to try to catch me out today?
How are you going to try to make me say
something that you think you can use to
discredit this movie?
Because that's what they're all about.
Now, why are they all about that? I wish
I knew. Are they bought? Are they
stupid? Are they bought and stupid?
I don't know.
Are they so determined to hate the
United States and hate Judeo-Christian
civilization
that they ally with its about enemies?
I think that has a lot to do with it.
But anyway, even worse than that is that
the US government signed on to it.
Now, this was a this was a gradual
thing.
But it's been coming for a long time.
The US government signed on to it
starting right after 9/11, really. When
George W. Bush went into the mosque in
Washington.
And behind him were standing Nihad Awad,
who is the co-founder and the still the
executive director of the Council on
American Islamic Relations, a group with
demonstrable ties that have been
affirmed by the Justice Department with
Hamas and the Muslim Brotherhood.
Also there as our caller was Abdurahman
Alamoudi, who's now in prison for
funding Al-Qaeda.
They were the leading moderates
that he could get to stand with him in
Washington.
And he said, of course, as we all know,
he said, "Islam is a religion of peace."
And you know, at first it seemed like I
thought, I remember thinking, and a lot
of people I know, probably many of you
thought at the time,
"He doesn't really believe it. He knows
better.
But
he has to say that. It's It's politics,
that's all.
Right?"
Except then he just kept acting as if it
were true.
More and more and more.
So, I was used to go I used to be a
trainer as uh was was noted in the
introduction, I used to train the FBI
and the CIA.
I wasn't supposed to say the CIA, but I
figure all bets are off now.
I was at the CIA, ladies and gentlemen.
That's quite a place, too. You go in
there, you know, you have to practically
strip to your shorts just to get in the
building.
And uh
then you go in and you know, it's funny
because everywhere else, when you go to
the FBI or to a military group, there
are usually people they're all sitting
around a table and they all have name
plates in front of them. You know, John
Smith and Tom Jones, not the singer, and
uh
various others.
And in the CIA, though, it's all Fred,
Joe, Bill, Tom.
I mean, why do you even have the name
plates at all, you know? Just call
yourself number one and number two and
number three.
But anyway, or 86 and 99.
Um
But anyway,
in those places, I used to tell people
about Islam and jihad. Bring the Quran
and teach them about Islam and what
Islam teaches in its various sects and
schools about warfare against
unbelievers and subjugation of
unbelievers and so on. The things, in
other words, that make jihad terrorists
fight us.
The teachings that they believe in.
Because obviously, you cannot defeat an
enemy that you can't understand.
That is one of the oldest tenets of
warfare. You have to know your enemy.
And so, that's what I used to do.
Many times when I went into those
places,
they would tell me
not to talk about it.
And I didn't. Not I don't mean not to
talk about the subject matter. I did in
the talks, but they would say, "Don't
say you've been here."
And that always nettled me, you know?
Because it was don't say you've been
here because CAIR will make a fuss about
it.
And I used to say, I remember one time,
and this is when it all started to blow
up. Really, in a certain sense, I shot
myself in the foot, but I don't really
regret doing so. This is how it
happened. In 2010,
one of the last times, if not the last
time that I ever did this kind of
training,
I did it for about 5 years,
off and on, you know, every few weeks,
every few months.
Anyway,
I was at a military base in Louisville,
Kentucky,
and the colonel, the head of the base,
he brought me in to his office before I
gave the talks, and he said, "We're very
happy that you're here. We're looking
forward to hearing
what you have to say, and please don't
tell anyone you were here."
And I said, "Sir, with respect,
I I I have to tell you I object to the
idea that we're letting a group with
ties to Hamas and the Muslim Brotherhood
tell us who the military can and cannot
listen to."
That would be like saying, "Well,
we can bring in a guy in 1942 to tell us
about what what Mein Kampf is all about
and what the Nazis believe, as long as
we bring in a Nazi the next week to tell
us that it was all wrong and it's really
a
belief system of peace."
It would be just as absurd.
So, we agreed to disagree,
but there were a couple of
lower-level
officers, actually the ones who were
responsible for bringing me there,
and they agreed with me that we should
not kowtow to this or acquiesce to this.
And so, they agreed to pose for a
picture with me, which I put up at my
website, Jihad Watch.
And sure enough,
days later, the Council on American
Islamic Relations put out a press
release saying, "Spencer spoke at this
military base in Louisville and spread
Islamophobic hate and so on,
and we demand that he be dismissed as a
trainer for the military."
And they found out that I had spoken to
the FBI and to joint terrorism task
forces and so on. And they started this
huge drive. I was amazed. They got Jesse
Jackson to
I kid you not, to to tell Robert
Mueller, who was then the head of the
FBI, that he ought to get rid of me.
Well, wow, Jesse Jackson's hurting me.
That's kind of
But anyway,
um
they worked.
They started to expand the effort.
They named other trainers. It culminated
on October 19th, 2011. This took quite
some time and built in force. But on
October 19th, 2011,
57 Muslim organizations and allied
organizations wrote to John Brennan, who
was then Homeland Security Advisor, and
is now of course the head of the CIA.
And they told Brennan
that Spencer had spoken in Louisville at
the military base and that this was
terrible and other Islamophobic trainers
had spoken here and there.
And
that there were materials on FBI offices
and so on, like my books, The Truth
About Muhammad and The Politically
Incorrect Guide to Islam, and other
books that were Islamophobic and
hateful.
And that this was terrible. They didn't
actually say any of the information in
them were false.
They pointed out some things, like for
example, there was some PowerPoint
presentation by someone, not me, that
said some signs of radicalization are
when secular Muslims suddenly grow long
beards and wear caftans and start going
to mosque regularly and carrying around
a Quran all the time.
And they said, "How dare this? This is
terrible Islamophobia." But actually,
that's
just true.
Um
Mike Hawash, you know, Maher Arar Hawash
was a uh
Muslim in in Portland, Oregon, who
worked for Intel, the uh computer group,
and he uh, was uh
was very well regarded in the community.
He was a pillar of the community,
involved in all sorts of community
activities, and so on. Uh, very secular
Muslim. No beard,
ordinary Western dress,
no sign that he was, uh, involved in and
didn't go to mosque, none of that. Then,
all that changed. For whatever reason in
his life, some crisis in his life, some
trigger in his personality, he grew his
beard, he started wearing Muslim dress,
he started going to the mosque all the
time. Then, he served 7 years in prison
for recruiting for al-Qaeda.
These were signs that something was up
with Mike Hawash.
And so, it's perfectly legitimate to say
that in the training materials.
But, it was just offered
as evidence of the horrible Islamophobia
of these training materials.
Brennan got this letter, wrote back
almost immediately.
And as if to emphasize how seriously the
Obama administration took this, he wrote
back on White House stationery.
Now, you understand, the president lives
in the White House. Usually, if you get
a letter and it says White House,
Washington, D.C., it's from Barack
Obama.
For John Brennan to write on White House
stationery means Barack Obama's behind
this 100%.
And
cuz you know, he has his own We pay so
much money in taxes. They got all They
all have their own little stationery,
their own letterhead.
Every one of them.
They don't have to share.
So, anyway,
he wrote to back to Farhana Khera, who
was the head of Muslim Advocates, which
is a Muslim lawyers group, tied to the
Muslim Brotherhood, of course. And
she had been the one who had written the
letter that was co-signed by the 57
organizations.
And he said how seriously they took
this, they were were to immediately
comply, they were going to remove
uh all the trainers who were
Islamophobic. They were going to scrub
all the counter-terror training
materials of any mention of Islam and
Jihad in connection with terrorism.
Because as we all know, it's a religion
of peace, and as Brennan himself has
said, Jihad is a noble concept involving
spiritual struggle.
And so we don't need to be talking about
Jihad in connection with terrorism.
Actually, after all, whoever heard of
Jihad being connected to terrorism?
It's absurd.
And so,
he not only said that, but he said,
"We're not only going to scrub all this
material.
We're going to re-educate any agent who
was in taught by these Islamophobic
trainers or by this Islamophobic
material."
Re-educate.
Chuck Schumer now is very pleased, I'm
sure.
Anyway,
this was in 2011.
Remember.
Now, as you all know, the Boston
Marathon bombing
was on April 15th, 2013.
And it was done by
Tamerlan and Dzhokhar Tsarnaev, who were
Muslims from the Caucasus.
And they did it, according to Dzhokhar,
the the the surviving brother, to defend
Islam.
And the Tamerlan Tsarnaev had actually
followed that path of radicalization
that the FBI now dismisses as
Islamophobic to look into. He had been
very secular Muslim,
who had been
wearing western dress and was
clean-shaven,
and never went to the mosque.
And then suddenly, for whatever reason,
whatever complex of reasons in his life,
he changed, he grew his beard, he began
going to mosque, he affected Muslim
dress, he started telling everybody that
they ought to be reading the Quran and
cutting out the
various things they were doing that were
against Islamic law.
And we, as we know, he blew up the
Boston Marathon,
killing three people and wounding over
260, maiming some of them like.
Now,
that was April 15th, 2013. But in 2011,
right around the same time that John
Brennan was assuring these Muslim groups
that there would be no mention of Islam
in connection with terrorism in any
counter-terror training materials, the
Russian government contacted the FBI and
they said, "There's this fellow you
should know about, Tamerlan Tsarnaev.
He is, and I quote, this is what they
said. They said, "He is a follower of
radical Islam and a strong believer
who's tried to join underground groups
in Dagestan."
Dagestan is in the Caucasus. The only
underground groups in Dagestan are jihad
terror groups. Al-Qaeda is very active
there.
So, if Tamerlan Tsarnaev was a follower
of radical Islam and a strong believer
who tried to join underground groups in
Dagestan, then he was a jihad terrorist.
If I had been
asked, and of course I wasn't,
if I had been asked in 2011 what they
should do with that information, I would
say, "Watch that guy like a hawk. Don't
let him out of your sight.
Keep him under surveillance
and make sure
that he is not getting involved in jihad
terror activity."
The FBI did not do that. They made a
perfunctory investigation and they
dropped it. And on September 11th, 2011,
the 10th anniversary of the 9/11 jihad
attack in New York and Washington,
Tamerlan Tsarnaev
went to see three of his friends, or as
close as he had to friends, in Boston,
who he had worked he had boxed with and
had other interaction with. They they
they went to the same gym and so on.
And they were his friends. And they were
Jews. And he slit their throats.
And murdered all three of them.
He was not caught.
It was never connected that he was
involved.
It was only after he blew up the
marathon that it came out from one of
his friends in Florida
who was being questioned about his
his knowledge of Boston Marathon bombing
Jihadist. And he spilled the beans that
Tamerlan had killed those three guys.
Now, what if the FBI had had him under
surveillance at that time?
Maybe those guys would be alive today.
Or if they had to be killed,
which God forbid, but you know, if they
were going to be killed and the FBI
couldn't prevent that,
then at least they would have known,
"Wait a minute. These guys happen to be
all three of them friends with the man
the Russian government told us is a
follower of radical Islam who tried to
join underground groups in Dagestan. And
you know,
Islamic Jihadists don't like Jews."
Really?
And so, maybe we should call in Tamerlan
Tsarnaev for some questioning about
these murders. And maybe if they had,
then he would never have been around to
blow up the marathon.
He would be in prison today.
Now, why didn't they do that?
Well, there's several reasons. In the
first place, they have no idea, I'm
sure, that Islamic Jihadists don't like
Jews.
They don't. Why? Because that's in the
Quran. Chapter 5 verse 82 says that the
worst enemies of the Muslims are the
Jews.
But they're not allowed to read the
Quran.
They're not allowed to know anything
about Jihad doctrine.
That's Islamophobic.
They got rid of all that right around
the same time the Russians told them
that this guy was a jihadi.
And so, see,
you have two choices if you're the agent
who gets that memo from the Russians.
Maybe you're part of the new regime, and
you've been trained by the John Brennan
people.
And so, you know that jihad is an
interior spiritual struggle for
bettering one's life.
And it has nothing to do with violence.
Only greasiest Islamophobes think it has
anything to do with violence.
And so, you hear the term Anwar
al-Awlaki is a jihadi, and you say, "Oh,
how nice."
Or, you're one of the old regime.
Maybe you heard me speak. Maybe you
heard somebody else speak who said the
same kinds of things.
But, you know that Washington doesn't
want to hear this.
That at the highest levels
in the White House, they don't want to
talk about Islam in connection with
terrorism.
And so, the Russians told us he was a
follower of radical Islam. Well, so
what? We know that doesn't have anything
to do with terrorism.
And so, they would have been maybe too
prudent to speak out.
They didn't want to be charged with
Islamophobia.
In the FBI, maybe lose their promotion,
lose their position, get reprimanded.
So, they let him go.
No problem.
Until the Boston Marathon happened.
It's the same thing with Fort Hood.
You recall that on November 4th, 2009,
Major Nidal Malik Hasan, an Army
psychiatrist, murdered 13 people at Fort
Hood while screaming Allahu Akbar
after he had passed out Qurans that
morning
to passersby
and told his neighbor that he was on his
way to do a great work for God.
Which is, of course, what we know that
all people who perpetrate workplace
violence do?
So, Major Hasan,
same thing.
Remember Brian Morgenstern, the kid in
the video store, and he was afraid that
maybe to report those guys would be
racist?
Well, I didn't tell you, he did actually
report them. He decided to go ahead and
be a racist bigot and Islamophobe. And
he reported them, and the plot was
foiled. At Fort Hood, the same thing
could have happened and should have
happened, but it did not happen.
And it did not happen because of this
regime of pretending that there is no
jihad threat, and that Islam is a
religion of peace.
This is what happened. Major Hasan got
glowing performance evaluations from his
superiors. I have them in the book.
They say, for example, that he
could teach American soldiers a lot
about Islam.
And he did, didn't he?
But not in the way they expected.
And not in the way that they're even
willing to learn now. That is, maybe not
the rank and file, but certainly the
superiors.
They said that
even though they knew
when they were saying it
that Major Hasan had been in touch with
Anwar al-Awlaki
and had been emailing him regularly
asking him about points of Islamic
doctrine and about the parameters of
jihad.
Anwar al-Awlaki, the jihad terror
mastermind.
Anwar al-Awlaki, who was the Imam of the
Dar al-Hijrah mosque in northern
Virginia, and two of the 9/11 hijackers
went there.
Anwar al-Awlaki, who was involved in the
plotting of the the underwear bomber,
the Detroit kid who hid hid the bombs in
his underwear and uh
tried to blow up the a over Detroit on
Christmas Day a few years back.
Anwar al-Awlaki who was involved in
other jihad terror plotting in the
United States.
And they knew he that Hassan was in
touch with him.
They also knew that Hassan, when he was
supposed to be giving a lecture about
psychiatry, army psychiatrists I I don't
know if this is true in other fields,
but they have this thing grand rounds
where they teach each other. And all the
psychiatrists get together and one of
them gives a lecture about the latest
discoveries or whatever. The new way of
madness or whatever. And
Hassan's turn came to give his.
And
he talked all about jihad.
And about how it was the responsibility
of the Muslims to wage war against and
subjugate the infidels. And that the
infidels would be punished in this life
by that jihad and then the next life
having molten lead poured down their
throats and so on. That's in the Quran.
And some of his coworkers, some of his
colleagues were terrified.
And they were talking amongst themselves
and only came out afterwards, but they
were talking amongst themselves saying,
"We think this guy could go jihad
himself sometime."
And they were frightened.
If anybody should have known that, it
was his superiors.
There was an FBI agent who was
monitoring Malik
Nidal Malik Hassan's communications with
al-Awlaki. And he kept sending them up
to higher-ups in the FBI in Washington.
And they kept coming back saying, "Not a
product of interest." That is, "We don't
care."
And this happened four, five, six times.
Always, "Not a product of interest. Not
a product of interest. Not a product of
interest."
So finally he contacted one of them
and he said, "How could this not be a
product of interest? Al-Awlaki is always
plotting jihad mass murder of Americans.
Here's this guy in constant contact with
him.
How could this not be something you care
about?
And you know what they said? They said,
"Do you know that we can't monitor every
Muslim soldier who wants to goes to
terrorist websites?"
You can't?
They do.
We And besides, this is sensitive
politically. Why sensitive politically?
Because they wanted Muslim soldiers.
They wanted a Muslim Army major. They
wanted to show that they weren't racist,
bigoted, and Islamophobic. Because CAIR
kept telling them that the war on terror
is a war on Islam.
And so, they had to prove, "See, it's
not a war on Islam. Look, we have this
wonderful Major Hasan that we love.
Promote him."
If
they had done otherwise, you can imagine
immediately what would have happened.
If they had said, "Well, you know, Major
Hasan, we have to bring him in for
questioning.
We have to ask him about what he's doing
talking to Anwar al-Awlaki, what his
plans are, what he thinks about jihad,
what he thinks about terrorism."
Imagine what would have happened if they
had done that.
You know, you could just see it on CNN.
You know, and tonight's guest is Ibrahim
Hooper to talk about Islamophobia in the
military.
And the horrible racism that Muslim
soldiers are subjected to simply for
expressing their faith.
And there would be task forces. I'm
sure, you know, Barack Obama would say,
"We can't tolerate this.
Let me be clear.
We're not going to accept
any Islamophobia in the US military."
And he would appoint some uh task force
to to root it all out. And you know, you
know that the career that would have
been ruined would not have been Malik
Me- Major Nidal Malik Hasan's. It would
have been that of his superior who
reported him.
And they didn't take the risk. You know,
I mean, who of who of us wouldn't? It's
a hard thing to say, "Well, I can commit
career suicide now to try to head off a
jihad attack, or maybe I can just let it
go and hope for the best."
I can understand why they did it.
But still, 13 people are dead.
And then General Casey, the
uh the
the Army Chief of Staff, said it would
be even worse
than the attack, even worse than the
murder of 13 people, if our diversity in
the military were to suffer.
In other words, we're keeping Muslim
soldiers, we're going to keep on doing
the same thing, we're going to keep on
bringing these guys in who might hate us
and want to kill us, and just hope for
the best, because we want to keep up
this appearance.
And this is the situation that we're in
because of this large-scale effort to
discredit any resistance to jihad terror
as bigotry and hatred and racism.
This is the reason why the jihadis are
advancing aggressively and confidently
all around the world today.
The jihadis' best friend in the United
States are these groups that have so
like CAIR, chiefly CAIR, but not solely
CAIR, that have so successfully planted
it in the public mind and even in the
government and the media,
that to resist jihad terror, to oppose
jihad terror, is wrong.
That it's better to get blown up, it's
better to get killed,
than to do anything about it. Case in
point, you know, a lot of people are
just hearing about Boko Haram
for the first time this week.
I know probably most of you or all of
you have heard of Boko Haram for years.
And I've been on Boko Haram for years, I
can tell that. If you go to my website
Jihad Watch, jihadwatch.org on your
dial. If you go there
and you search for Boko Haram, you will
find, I believe it's 115,000 hits.
That is, I've mentioned Boko Haram, I've
reported on their activities 115,000
times over the last 11 years.
If you go to the website of the Council
on American Islamic Relations
and you search for Boko Haram, there is
one response. One response.
That is, they never have talked about
Boko Haram.
In other words, this is the situation.
The only people who were standing up for
the victims of Boko Haram were the
racists.
The only people who were speaking out
against this violence and oppression and
almost daily slaughter were the bigoted
Islamophobes.
Yeah.
And so, once you discredit all the
bigoted Islamophobes, there is no one
left to speak out.
And that's what they want.
See,
the Council on American Islamic
Relations issues various issues periodic
reports on Islamophobia.
And
they're all about, you know, me and uh
Pamela Geller and Nonie Darwish and Wafa
Sultan and all these people who are
terrible bigoted racists and
Islamophobes.
Now, what was interesting was in the
last report,
they said there is legitimate criticism
of Islam and Jihad.
But these people are out of balance.
And you see, that's a very potent thing
to say. That's a very effective thing to
say. It's very clever. You got to hand
it to them, these guys are very slick.
It's very clever because they're saying
that we're not against anti-terror
efforts. We're not against, even
criticism of Islam. We're only against
these people. It's just these people are
crazy. These people are racist bigots.
These people are ignorant frothing hate
mongers.
The only thing is is that they never
name the other ones. They never name the
reasonable ones. They never name the
good ones. There really isn't any. It's
just a It's just a trick. It's just a a
slight of hand. They want you to think
that they think there's reasonable
criticism of Islam, but they don't
identify any reasonable critics of Islam
because actually any critic of jihad
terror in any way, shape, or form, no
matter how mild, is a racist bigot and
Islamophobe.
Every last one.
They don't want to have a legitimate
discussion. They don't want to have a
legitimate debate. They don't want to
have a give-and-take of ideas. They want
to shut down any criticism of jihad
terror so that there's only jihad terror
with not a peep anybody daring to say
against it.
And so that's the situation that we're
in. That's the state of the world today.
What are we going to do about it?
Well, obviously, the only thing we can
do about it is to stand up
courageously, no matter what the cost,
no matter what it takes, and no matter
how they ruin our reputations. You know,
I can tell you I admit I cringe, you
know, people The other day I was uh
Oh, I was at the um computer store. I
was having trouble with my computer and
you know, these kids today, they know
all about that stuff. And so I went into
the computer store
and
the guy started asking me as he's fixing
my computer what I did. And I said,
"Well, you know, I'm a writer."
And "Oh, what do you write about?" Well,
I write about terrorism.
And he says, "Oh, really? Well, I'm very
interested in that. What what kind of
things do you write?" Well,
I write about Islamic doctrine and
jihad.
Oh, well, that's fascinating. Uh
have you written any books? Well, yeah.
A few.
And anyway,
so I finally, you know, I show him the
uh
Amazon author page and the whole deal.
And the thing is I realized, you know,
I'm cringing.
And I'm ashamed. I'm not ashamed of my
work. I'm very proud of my work.
And I stand by everything that I've
said. I have no regrets.
But the thing is is that I knew that
once I left the store, he was going to
do a Google search. And he would see,
"Oh, oh, oh, I thought this was a
reasonably good guy. He's a recent bigot
in Islam."
Oh, oh, I didn't realize this lucky
murders cats.
This is what they they they have done.
But we have to be willing to stand up to
it.
We have to be willing to take it. And
once it at a certain point it will reach
critical mass.
Jay Leno is actually a case in point.
Jay Leno doesn't know Islamophobia from
shinola.
He is a comedian. He's a talk show host.
But he doesn't like the idea that gays
don't have equal rights in Brunei.
He doesn't have any idea what that has
to do with Islam.
But by golly, he's standing up, so more
power to him.
And see, this is the thing. They have
the government. They have the media.
They have the educational system. They
have the entertainment industry. The
only thing we have is the truth.
And so we'll win.
Because the truth cannot possibly be
defeated.
The truth can be obscured. The truth can
be
shunted aside, but it just keeps coming
back.
For example, and I'll close with this.
The
Grand Mufti of the Caucasus
several weeks ago complained that in the
US there was so much Islamophobia that
there were actually people who link
Islam with terrorism.
And you know, you know who he was aiming
at? Us.
He didn't mean Tamerlan Tsarnaev. He
didn't mean Nidal Malik Hasan. He meant
us.
But the thing is is that that's not just
ludicrous to us.
It's ludicrous to everyone. Everyone
knows that it's the Islamic jihadists
who link Islam with terrorism. It's not
us.
They try to pretend that we're doing it
and that they what they do really has
nothing to do with Islam. They just
happen to be Muslims who happens to do
some act of violence for some other
reason altogether, even though they're
quoting Quran and everything to justify
it.
The truth will out.
And at this point, that is our greatest
hope. The situation is bleak. I'm not
going to sugarcoat that. The situation
right now is dire. But remember
Alexander Solzhenitsyn,
the Russian freedom fighter.
And he wrote about that living in a
totalitarian system was like
living underneath the sidewalk as the
concrete's being poured and the concrete
goes over your head and you are
obliterated. You cannot breathe. You're
you cannot see. There is nothing. But
then the blades of grass put through
concrete and break it.
And that's the truth coming out.
The truth is out. It is known.
We have allies we don't expect like Jay
Leno. I'm sorry he couldn't make it
tonight, but I have every confidence
we'll see him later. And we'll see many
more others as well because the blades
of grass are going to keep breaking
through the concrete.
And so never give up hope. The truth
will win. Thank you.
Thank you very much. You're very kind.
If you now have questions or comments,
please keep your comments to a minimum
and your questions to a maximum.
Agreements, disagreements, death
follows, whatever. I'll be glad to come
to your talk. I have one thing to give
you.
Anyway, you're going to do it with the
microphone? Uh yeah.
You're back.
Okay, yes, sir.
How do you explain to me that
there are six Muslim Brotherhood people
infiltrating the federal government in
the White and
that Obama has invited into the White
House to infiltrate our security
systems, our planning systems, uh the
FBI and
the
CIA? And how do you explain that?
I'm not sure I understand the question.
The question is how do I explain the
Muslim Brotherhood infiltrators in the
FBI and the CIA and so on in the Obama
administration?
Well, I think it's inexplicable, really.
I mean, it's a it's a shameful thing
that's happened. What is even more
inexplicable is that no one seems to
care.
And when Congresswoman Bachmann called
for an investigation, she was roundly
denounced as a racist bigot. This is my
microphone.
Problems with what? The microphone. Is
it really?
Can you hear me now? No. Very low. It's
going in. Yes, you're right.
Hello. Oh, yes.
Good evening.
So, is okay? Okay, so I'll have to hold
here.
Yes.
Uh
No,
anyway.
The Muslim Brotherhood in the White
House.
There is a very important point about
that. Bachmann was denounced as a bigot,
isn't it?
Yes.
Hello?
Bachmann was
Somebody has like this on Bachmann
I like her.
Hello? No, I think they're trying to get
somebody. No, yeah.
It was fine when you were speaking.
I'm glad of that.
Hello?
So, Bachmann was denounced for calling
for an investigation of the Brotherhood
infiltrators in the US government.
However,
Thank you.
Yes.
There was an Egyptian newspaper
in December of 2012, she called for the
investigation in the summer of 2012. In
December 2012,
an Egyptian newspaper boasted about the
Muslim Brotherhood infiltrators in the
US government and said that they had
turned the US government around from
being the foremost enemy of Islam to
being the foremost proponent of the
Islamic agenda worldwide.
And they named many of the same people
that Bachmann had named as being the
infiltrators. Muhammad Ali al-Bishari is
my favorite. I met him.
Muhammad Ali al-Bishari is from Texas.
And I was speaking in Dallas about 10
years ago and Muhammad Ali al-Bishari
came. He wanted to play the victim and
hear the great Islamophobe speak and
whine about how we were I was
victimizing poor innocent Muslims.
And we had words after the talk.
And in the course of our conversation, I
asked him about why he would work with
the Council on American Islamic
Relations when they had ties to Hamas.
And he said, "I don't know anything
about Hamas. If you want to talk want to
know about Hamas, I'll give you Khaled
Mashaal's email address, and you can ASK
HIM DIRECTLY."
KHALED MASHAAL BEING THE HEAD OF HAMAS.
Do you have the head of Hamas's email
address?
I don't either.
Mohammad al-Libiary, the great moderate
Muslim, he has it.
Not only that,
but Mohammad al-Libiary
spoke a few years back at a conference
in Dallas, a tribute to the great
Islamic visionary, the Ayatollah
Khomeini.
Now, this guy is on the Department of
Homeland Security Advisory Council.
He's a moderate He's was characterized
in the press as the leading moderate
Muslim in the United States.
And he went to speak at a conference
honoring the Ayatollah Khomeini, who as
far as I know was not all that moderate.
And I asked him about that, too, in
Dallas that day. And he said, "I didn't
know what that conference was all about.
They didn't tell me it was a conference
honoring Khomeini." Said, "Well, did you
show up and speak?" "Yeah."
Well, let me ask you this.
If I came to a meeting,
and I didn't know what the meeting was
all about, and I get there and
everybody's wearing clan robes,
and I think, "Ah,
I'll just speak anyway."
Do you think that Mohamed Ali al-Hashimi
would let me off the hook?
Do you think he should?
So, there you have it.
Obviously, this guy is not in the least
a moderate.
And yet, he is on the Homeland Security
Advisory Council. And he's just one of
several in influential positions. And
so, if you look at and I outlined it
actually in the book, the Obama
administration's foreign policy, it has
been completely and consistently,
without any deviation whatsoever, in
line with the Muslim Brotherhood agenda
and supporting pro-Sharia Islamic
supremacist regimes.
So, you got to think, well, these guys,
they're doing their work well. But, why
is it happening? Well, Barack Obama
obviously is sympathetic to the
Brotherhood.
Whether he's a secret Muslim or not, I'm
not interested in speculating. I don't
know. He doesn't answer my calls. He
doesn't return my emails. Nothing.
But,
everything he has done has been in line
with the Brotherhood agenda.
He clearly thinks, for whatever reason,
that Islamic law in a society is a good
thing.
And to be encouraged.
Yes, sir.
This is in regards to the First
Amendment, freedom of speech, how it's
being uh
murdered.
Uh how much longer you think I have cuz
I refuse to stop speaking about Islam?
How long do you think it'll be before I
go to jail?
I think that's a question. Can I just
try this now? Is this working?
Okay.
Anyway, um
this is a very important question. How
long is the First Amendment going to
last? How long is it going to be before
freedom fighters go to jail? I think I
don't want to be hysterical, but I think
that that is a possibility that could
happen sooner than most of us think.
And the reason is that, you know, so
many people are complacent about the
First Amendment.
And they think, well, you know, when I
speak to them about the war on free
speech and the attempt to shut down any
criticism of jihad and rule it out of
bounds, rule it illegal.
And they say, "Well, no worry about
that. We have the First Amendment."
As if the First Amendment is going to
jump off the page and defend itself from
attack.
The First Amendment is only going to
last as long as it has willing
defenders.
And at the in the White House, there are
many
people who are on record, including
Kagan and Sotomayor on the Supreme
Court, who have spoken about the need
for various restrictions on speech.
And remember Hillary Clinton saying to
Tyrone Woods' father, Tyrone Woods being
one of the people, the Navy SEAL killed
in Benghazi.
And the Obama administration, now we
know they were completely lying about it
all along, but they blamed that on the
video of Muhammad.
Linked the Benghazi jihad attack on the
And what did Hillary Clinton say to
Tyrone Woods' father? "We're going to
have that filmmaker arrested."
And they did.
The filmmaker, he had You got something?
Yes?
He's going to dismantle it.
It's got an evil spirit in it. He's
going to cast it out.
Hello? Oh, yes. Good evening.
So, anyway, um
where were we? Tyrone Woods. Hillary
Clinton. Hillary Clinton. The guy had a
past. The guy apparently, I don't know
him, but uh he apparently has uh a
criminal record and he was on probation.
And so, part of the terms of his
probation were that he would not go on
the internet.
And so they said, "Well, you must have
gone on the internet. You uploaded that
video."
And so they arrested him, they put him
in jail. He was in jail for months. In
the first place, how did they know he
uploaded it? Maybe somebody else did for
him.
But in the second place,
arrested and put in jail for months and
months for uploading a video?
Look, I ask you, this is This is
Southern California, and I'm not from
Southern California, but I kind of have
an idea that probably if you went out
into some of the areas of Los Angeles,
you would probably be able to walk down
the street for about 7 minutes and find
10 probation violators more serious than
that guy.
It seems to me to be not just likely,
but certain that he was singled out for
this violation, essentially this
violation of Islamic blasphemy laws.
And the part of See, the ominous thing
about the Benghazi attack and the
Benghazi cover-up
that very few people remark upon is
precisely that that the Obama
administration chose to blame the First
Amendment for it. They chose to blame
our freedom of speech for it.
They chose to pick out this video that
nobody ever seen or heard of
that had 17 views on YouTube before this
happened
and say it was all because of this. In
other words, if we just shut up
and we don't say anything that bothers
Muslims, then they won't kill us. And so
if we surrender, everything will be
okay.
And that's the ominous thing about it.
That he was a political prisoner for his
freedom of speech. That's very, very
dangerous. Yes, sir.
You know,
all these things are open, Mr. President
Obama.
I've been doing it.
But how many
the sleeper cells, estimated, do you you
know there are?
If they all combine, we are in a big
trouble.
Yes, I
Is this working? Yes.
It is. It's lower. It is working? Mhm.
Sleeper cells. There are sleeper cells.
The thing about sleeper cells is none of
us know where they are. They're
sleeping.
The sleeper cells, however, are real. Uh
in my book in 2008,
uh Stealth Jihad,
any self-respecting bookstore should
have it.
Stealth Jihad.
I have uh information from the uh FBI,
which was not as bad as it is now, and
there was an FBI agent who said that his
they were tracking Hezbollah sleeper
cells
in the US,
and that they had communications from
some of them saying that they were not
going to attack anything in the US right
now. They were getting what they wanted
very well without attacks.
And so, an attack would just be a
tactical setback.
It would just get them a lot of police
and FBI looking at them.
They can get more done without attacks.
And how they have How have they done it?
By demonizing any counter-jihad effort.
Yes, ma'am.
Yes, I've seen articles about Obama's
brother, Malik,
who I believe lives in Kenya,
and that he was granted within a few
weeks from Lois Lerner of the IRS a
501c3,
and so he gets all kinds of money, and
he gives it to the Muslim Brotherhood
who are killing Christians all over the
world, and Jerome Corsi wrote about this
on WorldNetDaily.
So, we could say that the administration
is funding the murder of Christians all
over the world, and why doesn't anybody
know about this? Well, everybody doesn't
know about this because most people
don't read Jerome Corsi. No, don't
disrespect him, but I mean, it's not in
the New York Times. It's not on CNN. And
so, most people have no idea. And it's
even worse than that.
The Malik Obama is the head of the
Barack H. Obama Foundation. Yep. Named
for the president.
And it is a 501(c)(3) organization
that was rushed through.
You know, Pamela Geller and I started
the American Freedom Defense Initiative,
and we applied for a 501(c)(3) status,
and about a year and a half later we did
get it, maybe even longer.
But it took a very long time to get.
Malik Obama got his, as you say, in a
matter of weeks.
And you know what the Barack H. Obama
Foundation does?
They build mosques.
They build mosques in Africa.
And in those mosques
they teach the same things they teach in
mosques everywhere. It's not like the in
the Obama mosques they have some
different Quran that says give the
unbelievers a hug
instead of kill the unbelievers.
Wafa.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
As you might know, I am originally from
Syria and I'm proud to be American.
But for me as a Syrian
I couldn't comprehend or even accept
the fact that I saw Mr. John McCain
shaking hands with Islamic groups in
Syria and calling them hero.
I couldn't take it. It was a very
shocking
turning point of my life.
And it was
as shocking as when I discovered Islam
was fake religion.
So, would you please
comment in a way that
might make me feel a little better?
I I wish I could make you feel better.
Unfortunately,
there's nothing good to say about that.
And the only thing that I can offer you
is the truth. And I do believe, however,
ultimately that the truth will out and
will win, and that
even as bad as it is, we have to
understand where we are first before we
can get to where we want to go. You
know, just like reading a map. And so,
the first thing we have to understand is
a lot of people come up to me all the
time and they say, "Well, you know, in
2016, maybe we'll get a good president
in there and all this will turn around."
Well, it's not going to happen. Because
the Republicans are almost as clueless
and compromised as the Democrats are.
And John McCain going there and
standing with these Al-Qaeda people and
saying they were great heroes is just
evidence, only one piece of evidence, of
how clueless the Republicans are.
The The fact is that
George W. Bush is responsible to this
for this to a great degree, but also
Grover Norquist, the head of Americans
for Tax Reform, who is the most
influential and powerful power broker in
the Republican Party. You can't really
run for national office in the
Republican Party without his blessing.
And he won't give his blessing to
anybody who is opposed to jihad terror.
He has received money from Abdurrahman
al-Amoudi, who's now in prison for
fundraising for Al-Qaeda.
He has uh supported various Muslim
Brotherhood operatives and candidates
and so on.
And the thing is that
what McCain and George W. Bush and the
establishment Republicans generally
think is that anybody who's opposed to
the obvious jihad terrorists are
moderates.
And so, McCain, he sees these groups
that he's standing with fighting against
other jihad terrorists, and he thinks,
"Oh, they're the moderates. They're the
good guys."
He doesn't know anything about Islam.
He's never cracked open a Quran. He has
no idea what Islam teaches. And so he
thinks, well, these this tiny minority
of extremists, they're the bad guys, and
these people are fighting them, they're
the good guys. And they must teach peace
and and justice and love.
This is the problem, that there is this
pervasive willful ignorance on both
sides of the aisle.
The fact that the Free Syrian Army is
fighting the al-Nusra Front in Syria
does not mean the Free Syrian Army is
moderate. The Free Syrian Army goes into
Christian areas in Syria and destroys
the churches and terrorizes the
Christians and kills people and drives
them out.
They're not moderates.
But they're fighting al-Qaeda, they must
be.
See, this is the kind of superficial
analysis and fantasy-based policy making
that prevails in Washington. What we
need is a complete change in the
political culture. And what we must do
is no longer tolerate these candidates
who will not give it to us, and who will
not speak out for the truth ABOUT THESE
ISSUES.
AND I HOPE THAT THE REPUBLICAN Party
will go the way of the Whigs at this
point.
And just disintegrate such that a group
can arise that's like the Republicans
arose in the 1850s to counter slavery
and to take a strong stand against
slavery instead of the mealy-mouthed
weakness of the Whigs and the Democrats
at the time. What we need is a party
that will actually stand up for American
national interests
and national security and speak honestly
about jihad terror. And I'm hoping that
with the confusion
of the Republican Party, that its
disintegration will be imminent, such
that we can bring about that new group.
I HOPE SO.
ON SEVERAL TALK SHOWS ON TELEVISION,
there have been people who said that
Sharia law is already respected in 24
states.
I find that hard to believe, and I want
to know what your opinion is. Is that a
total bogus claim? It's It's not totally
a bogus claim, but it's mostly a bogus
claim.
Uh it's not that Sharia law is respected
in 24 states. It's actually 23 states
that have had rulings in courts that
have made reference to Sharia in a
positive way.
And so, that is the reason why there are
so many anti-Sharia initiatives.
Because
uh judges are making reference to Sharia
in their rulings. The most notorious
case was actually one that was
overturned, but it's still a disquieting
uh incident to have happened was in New
Jersey, where there was a case of
spousal rape.
And the judge decided not to charge the
man because he was a Muslim. And in
Islam, there is no no right for a woman
to refuse her husband under any
circumstances ever.
And so, he said, "Well, the guy just
didn't know what he was doing was
wrong." So, he didn't charge him. Well,
he didn't know what he was doing was
wrong under Sharia,
but in American law, that's still
illegal.
So, that was overturned, but that's the
kind of thing we're talking about.
Isolated decisions and incidents, most
of them having to do with inheritance
procedures. The Quran says that a son
will inherit twice as much as a
daughter, and so on, things like that,
where judges have ruled that the the the
will can be probated according to
Sharia, and so on. These things are bad
precedents because Sharia is all a unit.
You can't really separate out marriage
law or inheritance law or whatever else
that seems benign
and isn't usually, but nonetheless seems
benign from jihad and supremacism and
subjugation of infidels. And so, it's
it's it's something that should be
opposed, but it's not as if 24 states
have accepted Sharia or allowed for it
or something like that. It's separate
judges rulings.
Yes, sir. I have a question concerning
the news networks
and the schizophrenic
commentaries of Was it Megyn Kelly had a
great commentary on the
issue of the honor diaries or the video
being shown at the 9/11 memorial. But
then they have guests on like Joy Behar
who wrote a book and I quote her uh
where she says that this has nothing to
do with Islam and this has nothing to do
with religion.
And then she had her on and so did
Glenn Beck.
And so they do well on one point and
then they turn around and do one
completely different that contradicts
our dealing with Islam on a rational
basis. Yes. What do you account that who
do we hold accountable to that that's
calling the shots on how they comment?
Well, like I said that there's
bipartisan cluelessness and also
pertains to the media and to Fox which
is supposed to be the alternative to the
ideological lockstep of the leftist
media of CNN and MSNBC and ABC and you
know, all the rest of them.
Um
Fox was supposed to be the alternative,
but Fox really is is pretty much almost
just as clueless. They will talk about
these issues, but they stop at a certain
point. Glenn Beck when he was on Fox
years ago, he said and I quote, "I have
read the entire Quran and I can tell you
that Islam is a religion of peace."
And you know, I I I would have said to
him, "Glenn, you have to read with your
eyes open."
It's the same thing with with Joy Behar
and Megyn Kelly.
Um
the idea that Sharia has nothing to do
with Islam is like saying the Ten
Commandments have nothing to do with
Christianity.
Or Judaism.
It's like saying the uh the the
resurrection of Christ has nothing to do
with Christianity.
Sharia is Islamic law that is derived
from the Quran and the Sunnah. The
Sunnah is the Hadith
that are the traditions of what Muhammad
said and did and rulings that are
extrapolated from them.
It is considered to be the law of the
law.
Rulings that are settled and are agreed
upon by Ijima consensus among all the
schools of jurisprudence, there is no no
no appeal from them. There is no
reforming them or changing them. They're
considered to be the law of the law as
much as Christians believe the Ten
Commandments are the law of God.
So, to say that Sharia has nothing to do
with Islam is ridiculous. But that way
they preserve the idea, which is above
all the thing that must be preserved,
that they are not Islamophobic, that
they're not attacking Islam, that they
they have accepted Fox has wholly
internalized the idea that it's racist
and bigoted and Islamophobic and hateful
to talk about how jihad terrorists use
the texts and teachings of Islam to
justify violence and supremacism. So,
they will talk about the violence and
supremacism more than CNN will,
but they won't say how it comes from
Islam or is justified by Islam.
Now, this is another thing where we we
just have to demand better.
And
call upon them to be more responsible in
their reporting. You can say, "Well,
sure, but you know, okay, I can, you
know, send a tweet to Megyn Kelly and
she's not going to care." Sure, but if
100,000 people do, she will care.
And we have to start. Right.
Yes, sir.
I think it was two summers ago the
United States Congress had an open
hearing on Islam in America.
Uh
conducted by Representative King, I
believe.
And he had speakers on there
educating people and and it came out
that uh
uh Islam is not compatible with the
United States Constitution. No.
It's a problem. Weren't it? This is two
So,
you think they'd you get a a hearing
like this, you know, that kind of
audience, and it went nowhere.
Yeah, it went nowhere for several
reasons.
One is
Congressman King, that he did a great
thing with that hearing. And so, in the
first place, I have to say that before I
start talking.
I'm sorry.
I'm here to tell you the truth, even if
it's inconvenient to you, even all of us
here. The thing that Peter King did in
the first place was he said that uh he
was talking about radical Islam.
It wasn't as if he was going to call
people like Robert Spencer to speak.
And I thought, wow, Peter King's a This
is great. Um
Jesse Jackson and Peter King?
The The thing about it is is that it
wasn't personal. It wasn't about me.
The point was he What he was saying was,
"We're not going to get into Islamic
doctrine here. We're not going to get
into say the idea that the hearings
established that Islam is incompatible
with the US Constitution." I'm sorry to
say that that that there was nothing
like that discussed.
And there was no such conclusion
reached.
They did talk about terror activity in
the among US Muslims, and uh uncovered a
good bit
of damaging information that is good.
I'm glad that that happened. But, here
again, King retreated from
discussing why these things are
happening.
See, it's not like I just
it's not like I just hate Islam that I
want these things discussed.
I don't hate nothing.
The thing is is that we have to
understand why these things are
happening if we're going to stop them.
And so, if King really wanted to stop
jihad terror plotting in the US, he
would have to go to why it's how it
germinates. And it comes from these
Islamic teachings. There was a fellow in
North Carolina, the University of North
Carolina at Chapel Hill, my alma mater,
Mohammad Reza Taheri-Azar. And Mohammad
Reza Taheri-Azar was a student there.
Few years back. He was not connected
with Al-Qaeda. He was not connected with
any jihad terror group. He wasn't even
involved in any Muslim group. But he was
a Muslim and so he started to read the
Quran.
You know in in in Islam you got to read
the Quran in Arabic. It's not the Quran
otherwise unless it's in Arabic.
Mohammad Reza Taheri Azar Taheri Azar
was Iranian. He did not know Arabic.
Most Muslims don't know Arabic. Most
Muslims are not Arabs.
Most of them recite the Quran. They're
reciting syllables they memorized. They
have no idea what it means.
I had a Pakistani Muslim tell me a few
years back and this is not a joke. He
was quite serious. He said, "I have
memorized almost all the Quran and I'm
very proud of my religion and one day I
intend to get one of those
translations and find out what it
means."
So Mohammad Reza Taheri Azar got one of
those translations and found out what it
meant.
And he realized that he had to wage
jihad against the infidels. So he rented
an SUV and he drove it onto the campus
of the University of North Carolina
trying to run down as many students as
he could.
He didn't end up killing anybody. He
injured nine students before he was
stopped.
But then he wrote letters to the student
newspaper there explaining with copious
Quran quotes
all about why he had done it
and why it was a good thing to do.
Now this incident was completely buried
but I bring it up because it's just the
kind of thing that Peter King's hearings
were not equipped to deal with.
Because he was not going to get into why
people are you know there's a lot of
talk about what radicalizes Muslims
because obviously a lot of Muslims are
not radical. They're just going about
their lives.
So what makes some of them start killing
us?
Well you hear a lot about well they get
radicalized on the internet.
Well okay but you know they didn't go on
porn sites to get radicalized on the
internet. What are they getting
radicalized on the internet by?
The Quran. Presentations of the Quran.
Presentations of the Quran's violent
verses and of Muhammad's teachings to
wage war against the infidels. But then
we can't go there. We can't do not go
there. And until we go there, we're not
going to be able to do anything
effective to stop it.
Yes, ma'am. Would you comment on Ted
Cruz's tweet?
Well, he seems like a likable guy. As
far as I know, he's never said anything
about this issue. If there is something
he said about this I've missed it. So,
I'm sorry.
Um
there's a lot of hope in people like Ted
Cruz because people think that they
represent the wing of the party that
will be more realistic about these
issues. I no longer have that hope
because of Grover Norquist and because
of the way the Republican Party has
gone. But maybe Ted Cruz will surprise
me. I hope he will or somebody will.
Yes, sir. Comment on Keith on Keith
Ellison.
Oh, Jesus.
The Minnesota
elects a Muslim congressman.
Well, Minnesota's always been pretty far
to the left.
You know, you can go back decades and
there was the Farmer-Labor Party, which
is essentially a socialist party, and
Hubert Humphrey, who was
a very good man in many ways, but he was
a socialist who wanted to have
socialized medicine long before Barack
Obama.
And
it was Minneapolis has always been a
leftist place. And so, you have a black
Muslim candidate for Congress. It's
irresistible to leftists.
They think, "Well, it would be racist to
oppose him and it will show how
multicultural we are if we have this
cool black Muslim congressman."
And the thing about Keith Ellison is he
actually is one of the main people who
ruined the King hearings because the
mainstream media coverage of the King
hearings became all about how he busted
out crying, remember?
He was weeping, just copiously,
uh at the hearings. Why was he weeping?
He was reading a statement, a story
about a Muslim
who was a fireman
in New York, and on September 11th,
2001, Trade Center, and he was killed
there.
And he was missing. It wasn't known
where he was. And because he was a
Muslim, said Keith Ellison, he was
suspected as being involved in the
attacks because he disappeared after
them.
And only when his remains were found,
was it shown that he was actually there
trying to save people.
Now,
the thing about that is is that it's
it's almost wholly false.
There was a Muslim who was a fireman who
was killed at 9/11 at the World Trade
Center. They just named a street after
him in New York City.
But he was never
suspected as being part of involved in
the attacks. There is no evidence
whatsoever that the racist, Islamophobic
mainstream media ever said that this guy
disappeared and we think he might have
been involved. No evidence whatsoever.
It that is a
a wholly concocted myth designed to
advance the idea that Muslims are
victims in the United States and ought
not to be subjected to scrutiny for
terrorist activities.
And Ellison's crying performance was the
whole substance of the coverage of the
King hearings in the mainstream media.
So that most people just thought, well,
this Islamophobic congressman,
this racist congressman tried to
demonize Muslims, and this Muslim
congressman got all upset and really
showed him up.
And that's what it was all about. His
theatrics were better than King's. And
so much of this with the media these
days is theatrics.
But listen, Keith Ellison, one last
thing about him. He's Brotherhood,
Muslim Brotherhood Congressman. There's
there's no no uh exaggeration there.
Keith Ellison took $13,500
from the Muslim American Society to go
on the pilgrimage, the pilgrimage to
Mecca. They financed his pilgrimage.
The Muslim American Society is a Muslim
Brotherhood organization.
It is universally acknowledged that the
Muslim American Society is actually the
primary Muslim Brotherhood group in the
United States.
Imagine if there were a Congressman who
took $13,500
to take a trip financed by the KKK.
Do you think nobody would care?
But nobody cares that Keith Ellison took
this money from the Brotherhood.
Now, that's just an indication of how
base and degenerate our political
culture has become. The Republicans
ought to have been all over that issue.
And yet they're cowed. They're afraid
because if they say, you know, Keith
Ellison, he's taking money from the
Muslim Brotherhood, then the Democrats
will say, "Oh, look at this racist
attack on our black Congressman."
And then they say, "Oh, sorry, sir.
We'll shut up about it."
And that's why we're in the fix we're
in.
Yes, ma'am.
Um
I know you and Pamela Geller were very
much involved in the um
the mosque near Ground Zero.
As a family member of 9/11, I lost my
son in it. I've been watching this
forever.
And I I've heard now that the guy that
owns
the the
What is it? Something Park?
It's a the street is Park Place.
Park Place, yeah. It's the Burlington
Coat Factory. It's on the
they're going to demolish the building,
and then we and then he's going to build
a museum. Yes. This is the latest
is What's happening with that?
Uh well, there are the the
Sharif El-Gamal
is a developer, real estate developer in
New York City. And he was the one who
was going to build the ground zero
mosque.
And then, uh, yeah, we did stop the
ground zero mosque. They were actually
going to break ground on September 11th,
2011.
10 years, 10-year anniversary. They were
going to break break ground for this
16-story mosque at the site of the
Burlington Coat Factory on Park Place in
New York City. Now, you have to
understand, the Burlington Coat Factory
is right around the corner from the
World Trade Center.
And on 9/11, when the jet airplane, one
of the planes hit the towers, the engine
of the plane
flew out and hit the roof of the
Burlington Coat Factory building,
crashed through the roof,
and severely damaged the building. The
building was condemned and was vacant
until a Muslim group bought it and
started having prayers there.
They want to They wanted to tear down
the ruined building and build the
16-story mosque. That was obviously
going to be a triumphal mosque, just
like the mosque on the Temple Mount, the
Dome of the Rock, and the Hagia Sophia,
which was once a great cathedral and was
then turned into a mosque in Istanbul,
and the Umayyad Mosque in Damascus,
which was once the Cathedral of St. John
the Baptist, and so on.
They were going to make it into
a triumphal mosque on the site of the
jihad attack.
We stopped them. 70% of the American
people were against them. We held three
big rallies at ground zero, the second
of which, on September 11th, 2010, we
had 20, 30,000 people there.
And then Keith Olbermann said the next
day, "500 angry Islamophobes gathered at
ground zero."
But we got the pictures. The The crowd
was amazing. I never saw so many people
in one place. But anyway,
they dropped it. They stopped plans.
Yeah.
They declared victory and got out,
actually, like Nixon in Vietnam.
They said, "Well, we built it. It's
there."
And they meant the the little mosque
that they have in the premises of Coke
factory building. And actually they
people fell for this, of course. The New
York Times was calling me and saying,
"Well, what do you think now that the
Ground Zero mosque is there?"
That's not what we were fighting. We
don't care if there are Muslims praying
there in the ruined building. We didn't
want the 16-story triumphal mosque
built.
But anyway,
now what they did
what he's done, Sharif El-Gamal, is he's
now announced that he's going to build a
three-story Museum of Islam
there.
And the thing is it will also be a
mosque. I actually ran into him. I was
in New York City, minding my own
business, walking down the street, and
this guy is saying, "Mr. Spencer, Mr.
Spencer!"
And so I thought, "Yikes."
The world order.
Yikes. I turned around and it was Sharif
El-Gamal.
And he wanted to chat.
We had a really interesting talk, and he
told me, "I'm going to build it. I'm
still going to build it."
And so I'm sure he's going to try, and
I'm sure that we're going to be there,
and we're going to keep him from doing
it.
Oh, one last thing though, one second
about Sharif. That Museum of Islam,
that's just as much of an abomination as
a triumphal mosque. Is there a museum to
Shinto emperor worship at Pearl Harbor?
About the glories of Shinto
civilizations?
No, of course there isn't, and it would
be an insult to have that up there. And
it would be an insult to have this
there. You can sing the glories of Islam
somewhere else.
Yes, ma'am. Do you think that
Holland and Belgium and France are going
to survive what's happening there?
Are they doing anything to pull out? As
the great philosopher Yogi Berra once
said, "It ain't over till it's over."
I never give up hope.
I think the situation is very dire for
all of us,
and especially Europe.
But even if they take over, it ain't
over. Even if an Islamic state were
declared in France, it ain't over.
Because I am confident that there are
millions, not hundreds or thousands, but
millions of people all over Europe who
are not going to want to live under
Sharia.
Is it going to be ugly? Yes. Is it going
to be difficult? Yes. Is it going to be
bloody? Probably. I hope not, but
probably.
But, I never give up hope, and I think
that as long as there are free people
anywhere, there's we've still got a
chance.
You know, the truth is very powerful. I
can tell you that
the Council on American Islamic
Relations, they write about me and Pam
Geller and other people so often, it is
clear that they're desperately afraid of
us. And who are we? We don't have
anything.
They've got the government, they've got
the politicians in their pocket like so
many nickels.
They've got the media.
They say they say jump, and then and the
New York Times says, "How high, sir?"
How high say he?
We got nothing,
and yet they're so afraid of us. Why?
Because we tell the truth. That's all,
and that's why we'll win.
Thank you very much.